hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday July 2nd 2018 what's going on how
Hey
as you can tell old freckles is under
the yeah I tried to do too much when I
was on the road and I'm just an old guy
enough and I ended up catching a cold
that was the middle of [ __ ] winter I
flew into Minneapolis the day of the
show I usually I use to fly in the night
before but now I got the kid oh and I
don't know you know misses a little bit
of you know heard whatever day is
possible so I flew out the day of then I
landed and I've learned this less than
fifty [ __ ] times and every time I've
got the sick I landed I was a little
tired you know cuz I had to get up early
to get there on time and I went right to
the gym
stupid [ __ ] move then I had to do two
shows and then I hadn't hung out with
virzi and [ __ ] Bartnik but I slept in
the next day next day I woke up I kind
of felt rundown I was like nah man I hit
the gym again I hit the gym again
[ __ ] [ __ ] then I take a steam then I
go on [ __ ] stage have one show it's
the end of the night I absolutely love
bartnik and Varzi and hey let's go out
again so we go out again and this time
we was we were at an outside bar up on
this rooftop and it's really cool you
know place and you know downtown
Minneapolis and I had a hat on but it
wasn't enough and I could tell when I
was you know Nicole just get you and I'm
feeling a little bit under just getting
like ah [ __ ] here we go
and I didn't have any vitamin since the
nother thing I forgot my vitamins all of
that dumb [ __ ] so I don't know so I
apologize for being so friggin late here
but however I want to thank everybody
it's one of the most fun weekend's I've
had as far as crowds and just what I got
to see in Minneapolis and Detroit
Minneapolis first of all did a theater
there on the the campus of the
University of Minnesota now I was joking
with the people there whenever I go
you know to a great campus like that my
first thought this is for all you young
kids out there I always think to myself
man I wish I studied in high school I
wish I tried this is [ __ ] amazing do
we drove by there was like a frat house
and there was like 10 frat guys sitting
in a circle playing some drinking game
outside this amazing fraternity you know
and I know everybody makes fun of them
saying they're a bunch of date rapists
and then this and then that and all this
[ __ ] but at the end of the day who's
making the robots that are gonna kill
all of us huh it's the Nerds
so we ease up on the frat boys they're
not all rapists you know some of them
just Lear
so anyways and I couldn't believe how
[ __ ] beautiful beautiful the
University of Minnesota's campuses and I
was saying on stage this is what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I am I you know without
ever seeing a campus I judge what it
looks like by how your sports teams are
doing if you haven't won a Big Ten
championship or an SEC Championship in a
long time I just figured your school's a
dump and it doesn't look good I might
learned that with Vanderbilt you know
Vanderbilt's never like you know I think
maybe in baseball they're good but they
never do anything in football never do
anything in hoop so that's like that's
like almost a community college then
Nate bargatze told me it was a big fan
of it was like no dude that's like it's
one of the best schools in the country
some of the smartest I can this
engineering [ __ ] egghead school right
but I went to university Minnesota's
like all [ __ ] brick I mean what I saw
of it was was incredible now I always
had that thought like why didn't I study
it wasn't that hard I was I was such a
[ __ ] [ __ ] or such a baby
couple do so object and just yeah did
you get through it you know what I mean
I didn't like to inhale rooms either but
I had to do them to get to do a [ __ ]
gig at University of Minnesota I stuck
with that right hang on
ah sorry it's gonna be a lot of that
Illya pause next time you know look some
of the math I get you know cuz I gotta
be honest with you like I was cool right
up until algebra and if I wasn't such a
[ __ ] class clown in a jerk-off I
wouldn't have to go to summer school
after algebra cuz it wasn't that bad if
I applied myself geometry I don't even
know what I don't I don't even know what
the [ __ ] was going on it was like these
conspiracy theories about shapes not
good spirit they were proven like the
nba's fixed was proven when they had
that mobbed-up ref and of course they
blame it on one guy they always blame it
on one guy I don't know how long people
will sit there and watch the NBA I'm not
saying all the games are fixed I'm just
saying no other sport is it finessed the
way that sport is finesse to make sure
they have these matchups that are going
to get ratings and it all goes back to
[ __ ] Larry Bird and Magic Johnson I'm
convinced of it they're still [ __ ]
terrified because they almost went out
of business in the late 70s our ratings
were way down you know but they all do
it like during this steroid era you
think the [ __ ] owners didn't baseball
like they didn't know what the players
were doing baseball was in a bad way
they canceled the World Series Cal
Ripken breaking Lou Gehrig's record was
all they [ __ ] had they juice up the
ball they make the ballpark smaller
these [ __ ] guys are going up there
looking like the dad and the incredibles
you know [ __ ] skinny legs and giant
upper bodies just driving [ __ ] over the
out of the frigging ballparks they knew
what was going on and then all of a
sudden the [ __ ] hits the fan and not one
owner got asked a question they oh I had
no idea you had no idea you're in the
business right I do stand-up comedy I
know who some of the up-and-coming funny
people are I I hear who's stealing jokes
I hear who's gonna be the next [ __ ]
whatever I hear who's maybe a [ __ ]
partying too much yeah you're ready you
know that's what you do [ __ ]
Lumberjacks they know who's jerking off
behind a redwood I mean they're in the
[ __ ]
in business so baseball was finessed
that way I believe right football what
they did was they just you know they
weren't satisfied with their fan base
and they just kept every [ __ ] rule
ended up being for the offense to the
point it was borderline illegal to you
know to [ __ ] cover a receiver now
everybody's out there putting up Dan
Marino numbers which is [ __ ]
ridiculous Dan Marino Dan Fouts those
guys played back when you could
borderline murder somebody stick them
and all of that [ __ ] I don't have one
year that year drew Brees I can't forget
what he threw for but it was just like
there was like seven people on pace to
break Dan Marino's record maybe not
seven or probably four in in one season
so it's finesse that [ __ ] way right
hockey I just I don't know what they're
doing they just that they finally got it
right
they finally got it right with Nashville
in Vegas and now they're going to
Seattle I think they're finally going to
take a turn and my only concern is that
it's going to become immensely popular
which is really a pipe dream but if it
becomes immensely the the reason why
hockey still [ __ ] great is because it
is sort of the Jan Brady the middle kid
like nobody's [ __ ] paying attention
to it so you meet the players they're
all cool they're [ __ ] down-to-earth
you know what I mean I don't know sorry
I haven't even taken any cold medication
this is just literally my intellect so I
can't blame anything here but basketball
I swear to God like the Celtics are
coming on right and the Lakers suck and
I remember thinking as a fan this sucks
we're gonna be good and they suck it's
like if the Red Sox are good in the
Yankee suck or vice versa it's not fun
alright and all of a sudden LeBron is
gonna move and where does he go to the
[ __ ] Lakers and next year there's
gonna be a bunch of free agents and the
Lakers will stock up and again we're
gonna go to the finals it's gonna be
[ __ ] Lakers Celtics you know if
anybody can get past that juggernaut of
of Golden State but like I don't know I
think it's all uh it's definitely
finessed like like a boxing promoter
putting together matches like the fact
that they let Kevin Durant go to the
Golden State Warriors and the last two
seasons have been an absolute [ __ ]
snooze fest it's like they you knew they
were gonna win it the second he went
there and they did you know they were
gonna go back to back and they did you
know what they doin in Golden State is
like what the [ __ ] Yankees did in the
early 2000s and the height of them
buying championships was when they got
[ __ ] a-rod anything post 1998 cuz I
loved that Yankee team I don't love the
Yankees but I love that team but 99 2000
the Clemens all of that [ __ ]
was all those pile on [ __ ]
Championships and then the Red Sox were
like well what the [ __ ] you know we're
in the middle of a 90 year drought
86-year drought here this is justice
this is the game we got to play this
game and this is the thing we haven't
stopped playing in that [ __ ] game I
mean nobody could be as bad as the
[ __ ] Yankees I mean remember they had
[ __ ] Giambi an a-rod and Jeter and
their [ __ ] infield it's ridiculous
they had two of the best shortstops in
the league in there in filth one
agreeing to play third base was [ __ ]
nuts yeah I mean whatever so anyways so
LeBron is a Laker and I guess I'm gonna
get my wish that they're gonna be in the
finals hopefully against us I mean
that's who I want to play and beat and I
like our coach better and you know I
know that they're gonna go out and get a
zillion guys because everybody in the
NBA wants to play in LA not cuz you know
partially because they love the Lakers
but who doesn't want to [ __ ] a famous
broad right who doesn't want [ __ ] 75
80 degree weather year-round I've said
this forever what do you want to do you
want to go to Boston racist Boston and
deal with the winter and [ __ ] sixes
and sevens or do you want to come to
racist LA bang supermodels and go to the
beach whatever the [ __ ] you want 12
months of the year we can't compete with
it I mean the uniform literally looks
like
sunshine hey speaking of that when I was
in Minneapolis I went by that [ __ ] I
look like an old [ __ ] like hockey
stadium and I would have thought it was
the North Stars old place had I not
known that it's where the Mall of
America is now that wasn't a [ __ ] red
flag yeah we're getting rid of the
hockey team and we're putting the
biggest [ __ ] ball ever I still don't
understand how that [ __ ] thing stays
open you know how do you [ __ ] you
know what the Mall of America is like
it's like having a TV show now and it's
just so many of them I would tell you
the time I was talking another comedian
and I told her how much I liked her show
and she was saying thanks and we were
talking for five minutes before she
realized I was talking about another
show that she had that just got canceled
and she was talking about a different TV
show that I didn't even know she had two
television shows and I had no [ __ ]
idea anyways so I went by the armory
thing there and I saw Jennifer Lopez
played there during the Superbowl I
guess they redid it but the coolest
[ __ ] thing ever about that venue is
that's where the Minneapolis Lakers with
George Mikan when their first four NBA
championships and that that baa
championship that the Lakers still call
an NBA championship which is [ __ ]
hilarious they somehow won one all right
before the NBA existed but anyways I
really wanted to go in there and take a
[ __ ] tour of it so so there we go I
know a lot of you guys are expecting me
to flip out that [ __ ] LeBron what I
don't give a [ __ ] I like who oh thank
you how are you lovely Nia thumbs up
nothing you feel rundown I didn't give
it to you did I I didn't get to get you
sick did I
all right okay okay bye
yeah my wife was sick too you know I was
also sick but you know my wife was also
kind of sick but I was really sick so
you know what was gonna happen right
she's gonna sleep in and I'm gonna
handle the kit that's just how it works
toilet wait you want to keep peace in
the house that's how it works you just
[ __ ] you baby the [ __ ] out of them
you know and I would love to say that
I'll be able to remember that for the
next argument so I could be like the
[ __ ] time I was sicker than you and I
don't [ __ ] want your daughter for OMA
I won't remember it I don't have that
ability
you know you [ __ ] with a woman in
like [ __ ] Matlock you know he'd
[ __ ] start pulling I didn't even
watch that show you know I imagine he
was pulling up [ __ ] cases from the
past I have no idea you know when he did
last night I was done that I couldn't
get the [ __ ] sleep I was on the
internet there and I was seeing watching
all this [ __ ] on Dean Martin and Jerry
Lewis just how big and how famous they
got everything and after they broke up
Dean Martin in about 1958 got in the
restaurant business and he opened up
Dino's Lodge which was basically just
west of La Cienega on Sunset just south
now this is giant [ __ ] complex there
but it's long gone I mean they knocked
it down in the 80s but he got involved
in there they put his big head there
Dino's lounge and he went down there and
it was a really hip place to go to at
first late 50s maintains Dean and he
would actually go down there you know
get the restaurant going starstruck
patrons he's signing autographs and all
that [ __ ]
and do you know like [ __ ] two three
laters Jerry Lewis opened a competing
restaurant down the street this is how
bad it got he opened a competing one and
then stole Dean Martin's business
partner to open that one and then he had
an even bigger picture of himself on the
restaurant and it was on a pole like a
hundred feet in the air
and it wasn't stationary it was
revolving so I guess Dean ended up
saying I'm and [ __ ] this [ __ ] he got it
cuz he's cool he said [ __ ] this he got
out of the restaurant business and then
he had to sue them to get his name taken
off in the image and he couldn't get it
taken off and they his face stayed on
that restaurant until like the [ __ ]
80s like I said well they finally
[ __ ] took it out but anyways I just
can't imagine that it got that bad which
of course led to me to the 1976 reunion
that they had on the Jerry Lewis
telethon when Jerry had no idea Dean was
coming out Frank brought him out
that was cool watched him hugging all of
that [ __ ] you know what I mean
stupid [ __ ] falling out stuff but I
just thought was funny at the height at
the [ __ ] height of them hating each
other they had competing [ __ ]
restaurants how not to comedians you
know I just picture Maxine like DeNiro
in casino counting the [ __ ]
blueberries in the muffin freaking out
doing that crazy Jerry Lewis voice
saying how Dido has more blueberries in
his muffin and this is [ __ ]
unacceptable anyways flour to adhere Oh
Billie is uh [ __ ] gonna hang around
the house here and get over this should
actually feel a thousand times better
than I felt yesterday I just need to
walk around they sent weird thing you
know when you get sick what you supposed
to lay around and relax and you know
eats you know it's it why is it eat soup
you know what I mean just slurp it right
it smell as hybrid things it's almost a
gas it's not a liquid it's not a solid
you know it is a liquid and it's a solid
that's what it is it's like a super
group of food no it isn't bill it's like
cereal if you heated it up what do you
put that you know do you know I saw when
I was on the road
I actually saw Pringles potato chips and
they had dill flavor and I love [ __ ]
dill pickles and I love Pringles potato
chips and those two came together and I
couldn't get myself to do it because it
just it was coming across like it was
gonna be like a supergroup you know like
what if we took [ __ ] Robert Plant and
[ __ ] stuck him with Keith Moon
they do [ __ ] like that and then it's
just and then it just never sounded good
because the vibe wasn't there I'm just
so worried that that's what it's gonna
be
and on some level like um you know it's
gonna ruin my enjoyment of original
Pringles and and dill pickles your
loveable Pringles they taste delicious
and I'm a bit of a neat freak although
my office is a [ __ ] mess right now
you know I hate [ __ ] dishes in the
sink the next morning it like depresses
me I [ __ ] knock them out yeah a
basically an incredible father and
husband is what I'm telling you that's
my version of it that's my version of
the story eventually we'll have Nia on
here when she's feeling better and then
she'll probably tell you the truth that
I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] over there did
anybody watch the [ __ ] Austrian
Formula One race that is my favorite
[ __ ] Formula One race that I've been
one that I've ever watched and I've only
watched since Monaco 2016 and I've
missed a few here they're absolutely
loved that [ __ ] race I'm a huge fan
of max Verstappen I feel like he's the
next guy him and Daniel Ricciardo right
and Daniel Ricciardo is gonna [ __ ]
leave Red Bull I don't know where he's
gonna go Ferrari I don't know if there's
room in the Mercedes team I have no
[ __ ] idea but it was just like the
top two guys what's-his-face max
Verstappen and Kimi räikkönen they're
[ __ ] hilarious their press
conferences are hilarious thereafter
they just they don't give a [ __ ] you
know they just they have like that
Comics comic vibe about him like I know
when I was talking about the last time
Sebastian Vettel had bagged into a
couple people and max Verstappen during
the for after the press conference ago
you guys should tell him he should
change his style of driving you know
because they had said that to him and
then to him Max earlier in this season
that he goes and then [ __ ] Sebastian
should continue to drive exactly the way
he's driving cuz that I haven't changed
anything and now you guys aren't
[ __ ] on me cuz I'm winning by the
way and then the United States the Hass
team came in fifth and six
it's like our highest place ever was it
fourth and fifth the fifth and sixth it
might have been fourth to fifth I gotta
look it up here I can't remember but I
Mercedes oh oh my god
they had a [ __ ] brutal day a brutal
date it sucks because I wanted they
always want to see like a close race at
the end but I got me I'm a little jaded
with this sport where I was just you
know after the first term which was it
was a [ __ ] incredible start to the
race and I remember when when Lewis
Hamilton got into first place after the
first turn I got it's over he's gonna
win it he's gonna win it but the track
was so [ __ ] hot that tires started
the blister some [ __ ] happened I
don't know what and what's-his-face no
we came in fourth and fifth grows you
know Magnussen fourth and fifth the hot
steam I don't know what happened
somebody was going too [ __ ] slow or
something that caused Lewis Hamilton to
have to slow down and then he got passed
and then he had to go into the [ __ ]
pits or so you had a did one extra pit
stop is what happened and that [ __ ]
him but that guy's such a good driver
even in the end the other guys tires
were starting to blister up and he was
she was just right [ __ ] there and
then all the drama went out when he
[ __ ] his car shut the bed and I
believe Valtteri Bottas had some sort of
gearbox failure but and also
what's-his-face Daniel Ricciardo his
[ __ ] car shut the bed - it's been
having a rough go of it but I just liked
it cause it just put different people in
the lead that I haven't seen I know max
Verstappen is done well over the last
few but it was it was just fun to watch
all of that [ __ ] and then watch Lewis
Hamilton having like the the fastest lap
of the race trying to catch up like Bill
Elliott back in the day in the stock car
races and then unfortunately his car
[ __ ] the bed but here's the big thing
was he was up 14 points
Lewis Hamilton / Sebastian Vettel Vettel
came in third and I believe you get 15
points
and Lewis Hamilton got no points so now
Vettel is leapfrog to pass him and he's
up one point because I was hoping he
wasn't gonna slowly [ __ ] pull away
I think they race again next week in
Great Britain and then they might be on
their break their summer break and then
they'll be neck and neck for the rest of
the year so for our Ferrari can [ __ ]
hang in there it should be exciting
right through Brazil and on into
November what do they always end up so
Dubai I can't [ __ ] remember
so anyways very [ __ ] excited about
that race I mean it sucked you know that
Mercedes got knocked out this is also
Daniel Ricciardo but it was just fun to
see some new blood up there and then you
know watching Lewis Hamilton putting on
a [ __ ] show as he was dealing with
the foot his tires literally falling
apart
anyways when I was when I was in also
when I was in Minneapolis I forgot to
tell you I was gonna try a different
place to get a Juicy Lucy last time I
went to Matt's bar and I got this
[ __ ] uber driver hilarious Indian guy
there's a lot of construction going on
downtown at Minneapolis and it said he
was five minutes away for 15 minutes he
finally pulls up and this dude was like
the [ __ ] old Indian version of me
like he was like snapping on me because
he was mad about construction but I
understood it because like it took me a
minute to figure out like why is this
guy yelling at me
I go I want to go to uh whatever the
[ __ ] was the five eight club was gonna
try that one next right and he goes I
need an address immediately yelling at
me and I go all right dude relax no you
can't just say that never the plays I
need an address I was like to stop
yelling at me he goes I'm not yelling I
go you don't you yes you are you yell it
and then virzi gets in the car he's
looking at me I'm like dude this guy's
[ __ ] that you know this guy's yelling
at me and he goes I need an address and
I'm like well the name of the place is
the five eight club putting your phone
your [ __ ] [ __ ] right so now I went to
his energy but fortunately I've been
really working on it and I brought it
back down again and I was just like hey
alright you know like I understand this
traffic here right listen and then he
was trying to smile his way through it
realizing he went to [ __ ] nuts so I
think I gave
address you have taken us to Matt's bar
so now it's like really tense Bart
Nick's riding in the front seat this
[ __ ] guy's like we're with our
[ __ ] angry grandfather we were all
trying to be on our best behavior
so Bart Nicks tries to lighten the mood
we see this fat chick on a bicycle you
know and she was at a dead stop and
thought she's trying to get it going so
it's just like you know it's precarious
when you start off a bike if you're not
pedal it fast enough especially when
you're carrying that kind of weight and
Barney was a Jesus Christ look at her
man because they don't have assets like
that and India do they he's like maybe
on an elephant right and the guy started
laughing oh it's like yeah there'd be a
[ __ ] sacred cow over there and we
just [ __ ] broke the ice we broke the
ice by making fun of a fat chick and
bringing up stereotypical [ __ ] from that
guy's culture that's how we did it and
then he pulled up he ended up pull it up
to Matt's bar instead of the 5/8 Club
and I was like oh this isn't where I
wanted to go and he kind of looked at me
I was just like - forget it it's alright
it's fine I just don't get yelled at
again I was looking like a battered wife
at that point like okay bye dad I love
you just [ __ ] throw Boff
all right let me read let me be a little
bit of uh by the way it was delicious
and they they have got millaa millaa
high life in a bottle there you know
what the dangerous thing about a Miller
High Life is there's just something
about the bottle it feels like it's
eight ounces it just doesn't feel like
it's 12 ounces of beer and they just
they just go down so easy you know and I
had a show that night so you know ended
up havin uh I think we had like two and
the waitress was cool you know she was
asking us about the show we ended up
hooking her up and then she gave us some
[ __ ] hats and [ __ ] it was really just
it was [ __ ] him in Minneapolis is
[ __ ] awesome the people up there a
[ __ ] awesome and then I go to Detroit
you know the [ __ ] great and I
actually was actually like as I just
literally landed went to the hotel and
then went out and did the show so I was
doing my typical Detroit material about
white people you know drive a hundred
miles an hour into the Tigers game and
after that you know and then drive back
out cuz it's so [ __ ] up in the
downtown area and I knew it was making a
comeback every time I go there it's a
little bit nicer but dude it's like
those jokes are over now I walked out
after my
about 10:30 at night and I saw a white
guy a white kid on a bicycle with a
backpack riding down the street not even
nervous and I was just like like it sits
in a real estate sense it's too late to
buy there you're already gonna be paying
like [ __ ] top shelf prices if the
neighborhood got to the point where a
white guy will ride down the street late
at night you know with a backpack on you
know he wasn't like a [ __ ] you know
he wasn't like eight mile Eminem white
guy he was a white guy like me you know
a suburban a suburbanite a non-dancing
suburban white kid
so anyways dad I got John Varvatos
downtown it was [ __ ] ridiculous I've
ever ago I was telling virzi going
through it I'm gonna buy some property
here this place is gonna [ __ ] blow up
because you're out of your mind I was
just like - it's an open take it's here
it's just what I saw this happen in
Pittsburgh I saw this happen in
Cleveland I just didn't have [ __ ]
money at the time was I was [ __ ] put
it in this goddamn you know [ __ ]
money pit of a house that I bought it's
a nice house now it's a nice house now
but I this is literally body off
restoration I had to do this [ __ ]
house sorry anyways and I remember
seeing on the anthony bourdain show
parts unknown rest his soul I saw a guy
he bought a skyscraper there for five
million bucks and I was thinking those
anyway you could scrape together five
million bucks and then renovate it which
I don't know what that would cost
another fifty forty five and if you
could just sit on that I mean there's no
way that it's a skyscraper when that
city makes a comeback that thing you
know say his sixty billion it's gonna be
worth a quarter of a billion dollars and
you know who [ __ ] did all that [ __ ]
the the owner of the Cleveland Cavaliers
he went down there he bought a bunch of
[ __ ] buildings redid him had made the
office space cheap and he filled them up
with these Internet companies and made
me feel good then I was gonna make the
same move that a billionaire [ __ ]
owner of a basketball team was gonna
make I just didn't have the [ __ ]
money any
but I'm very very happy for that city as
I was for Cleveland as I am for
Pittsburgh and all that [ __ ] cuz they're
such great cities Buffalo Baltimore all
of those cities going right through
there
Dayton I love all of those [ __ ]
cities and they and all they need is
just people to [ __ ] invest in them
you know what I mean
I'll tell you when we're done free in
the Iraqis we should ought to come back
here and try to help out some of these
[ __ ] cities get him going again start
building [ __ ] you know if I was runnin
[ __ ] I'd have these [ __ ] hipsters
right I would just have them like what
are you into right now what are you
gonna bring back from the past and do it
in some artisan [ __ ] way and you know
you just you know give a break on
factories and [ __ ] start making stuff
here again you know say what you want
about hipsters they like a lot of cool
stuff there just insufferable to talk to
all right the black box both sorry the
black tux I don't know that was from
watching too much porn or having a
pilot's license the black tux wedding
season is upon us you're gonna be doing
it big and going out to all your buddy's
weddings when you're bringing a date you
want to look fresh yeah you want to hook
up you don't bring a date you want to go
there like [ __ ] Jim Carrey and Dumb
and Dumber but have a cool tuxedo but it
has to be convenient that's where the
black the black tux comes in the black
tux has awesome suits and tuxedos and
all kinds of styles and you rent them
online all right I just hit pause and I
blew my nose while it wasn't recording
see I learned from my mistakes the black
tux offers the kind of suits and tuxedos
styles that would normally be wildly
expensive to buy and you might only wear
it once like the Emerald shawl tuxedo
it's funky it's cool but how many times
you gonna wear an emerald green tuxedo
with the black tux you can you can do
you and blow it out for your big event
one one-time event yeah you got it you
got to go with something a little bit
flashy and don't bring a [ __ ] date
automatically before you even open your
mouth you're gonna seem interesting
forget about when the ladies start
drinking next thing you know
you're out there doing the Macarena
right and you're like why would you ever
get married and that's called being in
your twenties
all right so try out a new look do
something different and take your style
to the next level with the black tux
free home try on you can see the fit and
feel the quality of your suits month but
four months before the event it's a hard
word to say plural months let me do that
for [ __ ] months I think I say months
mu 1s months mu NCE after ordering your
suit after ordering your suit will
arrive 14 days before your event if
anything is less than perfect the black
tux will send you a replacement right
away and remember how simple returns are
wear it turn heads and then send it back
three days after your event shipping is
free both ways stand out at your event
for the right reason with the black tux
you get $20 off your purchase visit the
black tux comm / / that's the black tux
comm / bar for $20 off your purchase the
black tux premium rental suits and
tuxedos don't all right here we go
lastly but certainly not least Lee
simply safe here's what I love about
simply safe these guys obsess over
details it's why the alarm system is so
good here's an example a typical glass
break sensor sometimes gets fooled of
false positive sounds like dropping
plates a baby crying oh then it freaks
out it says the British are coming or
the sky is falling
simply safe didn't want to settle for a
typical they want to settle for typical
because really good home security should
be really accurate so they actually
considered a glass break test facility
well they have a bunch of toddlers in
there throwing glasses they ran over
10,000 live
glass breaks simulations refining their
technology the detection technology
until it was so accurate it continues it
can distinguish a broken plate from a
broken window Jesus Christ can you
believe somebody knows how to like make
up [ __ ] a little piece of electronics
understand that even think I'm not
relevant you're going to be in ten years
this
the level of detail simply safe puts
into everything they do it sets them
apart from other security companies
simply safe system it's designed so you
will never notice it never have to think
about it it's that easy and intuitive
there's no contract they work hard to
earn your business 24/7 monitoring with
police and fire dispatch it's just 15
dollars a month it's the best around the
quad protection you can find protect
your home today visit simply safe burg
calm now that's simply safe / calm
simply safe / calm you ever think why
the people at the top are not concerned
about the environment generally speaking
and how they're content to just [ __ ]
use up all the oil kill as many people
as they need to kill to get the [ __ ]
oil you know pollute the air as much as
they can throw it the [ __ ] rivers why
they don't give a [ __ ] you know that was
just sticking I think it's because we're
all good you know all us regular people
are gonna get replaced by robots you
know what I mean they'll have robot
comedians you know robot [ __ ] [ __ ]
whatever the hell you want to get a
better kind of ran out of jobs there but
you don't I mean and then they're still
gonna they're still gonna live and
they're gonna be that upper 1% and
they're gonna have like just like
essentially an entire population that
never complains is totally into what the
[ __ ] they're doing I think they'll keep
a a group of people human beings as
slaves and their job will be to [ __ ] and
make more people so that these older
[ __ ] rich one-percenters can harvest
their organs and live forever
that's what I think those are the kinds
of things that I think when I'm alone
and you got to figure the first time you
kill somebody for that your organs
you're just gonna do that forever
because it's like well I don't think if
there's a higher power I don't think I
want to meet him or her with with that
on the resume you know God just sit
across to you love you were busy sitting
there shifting in that [ __ ] chair you
just [ __ ] know exactly what the [ __ ]
he's do you know exactly what he's
talking about like that one's gonna pop
up and you got everybody's got probably
that one thing except for truly good
people which I'm not
you know like if I you know when I die
if there was an afterlife I feel like
God's gonna like [ __ ] with you like you
sit across from him and he just looks
down at your resume right probably has
like the half glasses you know sitting
on the end of his [ __ ] almighty nose
eyebrows up and [ __ ] and I just kind of
looks across the gays probably like you
want me you want you want to tell me
about this you know and then you're
sitting there going ah [ __ ] what's he
talking about is this a trick
oh [ __ ] he can hear what I'm thinking
don't think about all the [ __ ] you did
Billy's gonna know it's gonna be such a
mindfuck anyways no that's a weird
[ __ ] topic huh dying with the [ __ ]
around my what the hell's all my [ __ ] oh
there it is it's trying to fight on Mike
Mike [ __ ] [ __ ] I wanted to talk about
Detroit's [ __ ] gorgeous white dude on
a bicycle too late to invest see that's
what I do I just write a couple of words
oh yeah that's what I wanted to talk
about anyways so I'm so psyched to be
back out here in Los Angeles you know
when I was in Detroit it's weird when I
was in Minneapolis
I ordered what they were known for which
is the Juicy Lucy which is a [ __ ]
incredible like the one at Matt's bar
they got this nice char on it then they
got the cheese of course in the middle
and it's molten hot so you got to be
careful nibble nibble around the outside
and so it was it was delicious
and then the beer was ice-cold it was
[ __ ] great it made me wish I didn't
have a show that night it was like I
think I want another one of these and I
want to sit here and just [ __ ] watch
a game you know and but then I went to
Detroit and
you know I ordered tacos
stupid [ __ ] move I mean they were
good but they weren't but you know
they're not la la knows is known for
tacos San Francisco is known for
burritos and I'm known for being pasty
oh let's talk world cup shall we let's
see what's going on in the Phi Phi World
Cup I watched a couple of games I can't
even tell you who the [ __ ] I saw I did
see the highlight so what I wanted to
watch was Brazil in Mexico you know what
I mean I mean that was just the [ __ ]
soccer supernova as far as I was
concerned about Russia beating Spain
that was like the [ __ ] Lake Placid
moment you know and I was sitting
immediately going like ah this is gonna
be weird as Russia keeps moving along
you know you watch America is gonna be a
bunch of babies about it you know
because everybody's already saying that
they kind of [ __ ] with our election or
whatever and uh you know first the
election now the World Cup they don't
like we give a [ __ ] what game did i
watch I watched the Dutch people play
[Music]
[ __ ] I can't remember but the other
people won or some of the best
goaltending I've seen in soccer ever the
[ __ ] game starts first of all the
Dutch guys right it was a Denmark
Denmark right they [ __ ] a Denmark
Dutch people is that the Netherlands
I don't know I'm an American they don't
talk about the rest of the world okay
they talk about the [ __ ] white people
that started this country that's what
gets driven into your [ __ ] skull so
the Denmark scores a goal like 40
seconds in or a minute in or something
like that and then like 45 seconds later
the other guys score the guys who won I
can't [ __ ] remember
Croatia so lochia Slovenia Romania
I don't know the [ __ ] it was
they [ __ ] score I'm like oh my god
this is finally my dream game Ben and a
half and there's already been two goals
this is some [ __ ] American can
appreciate and then there wasn't another
goal for like another [ __ ] hour and a
half but I do have to say the
goaltending was [ __ ] incredible
alright and that guy with this [ __ ]
golden [ __ ] locks there go come head
for [ __ ] Denmark was incredible and
then the other guy was just a [ __ ]
lunatic one of those guys you could tell
he can't shut it off after the game and
they were just guessing right they dive
and then the guy would shoot to the
middle he [ __ ] get his foot out while
he was diving the other way oh and
whatever you miss a penalty [ __ ] kick
like it's the shooter whatever you [ __ ]
you call him right they you know that
they're [ __ ] they're just thinking
like oh god I'm gonna get [ __ ] I'm
never gonna hear the end of this when I
go back to my country I'm never gonna
hear the [ __ ] end of this you know
unless somebody steps up and saves my
[ __ ] ass so I did see that game I did
see the Brazil game with that Ronaldo
guy oh my god I thought for half a
second he was literally on fire you know
like when Will Ferrell was running
around and Ricky Bobby with the
invisible flames he was tearing off all
his clothes I thought that that's what
was what was happening I mean I know the
guys definitely should have been a
penalty it was a piece of [ __ ] move the
guy stepped on him he raked his [ __ ]
cleat right across his ankle I imagine
it smarted but Jesus Christ that was
like silent film acting pennyways I
guess Brazil won two to nothing and
we're getting down to it so I imagine
France or England was playing today
right know France is gonna play they
were already in like they're already and
why don't I look it up FIFA World Cup
standings then you got to fight through
all these CBS Sports [ __ ] that don't
[ __ ] have it
I want the grid I want the bracket give
me the bracket
work up brackets CBSsports you gonna
[ __ ] me again CBSsports come on slowly
opening this [ __ ] website sucks
it keeps saying brackets it doesn't have
the bracket where's the bracket there's
nothing I can't can click on schedule
the standings already the [ __ ] playing
today World Cup schedule I'm clicking
and I are you [ __ ] a so russia 2018
schedule oh my god I found the bracket
all right oh I watched the Uruguay I
always I was Uruguay Earl Grey beat
Portugal I watched that game shut up
I watched Croatia be dead MA I guess
Sweden beats Switzerland for love of
thought I don't know why the
abbreviation for their country is Sui
there's no you in Switzerland why would
it be W is that too close to Sweden
Brazil is playing Belgium alright so the
last person who has to get in is is
England is playing Colombia when the
[ __ ] is that game I gotta take that one
then they get into the quarterfinals
then there's the semis and then there's
a final game [ __ ] goes by so fast
so one two this three basically three
more routes and I'm gonna watch it for
once I don't think I've watched a final
since that guy from Italy missed that
penalty shot you know and I remember
when I was a kid way back in the
eighties Diego Maradona the hand of God
and all of that [ __ ] but other than that
I mean also was in the it wasn't in the
US and like 94 and like 30 Americans
showed up but it still sold out because
everybody around the world was like so
excited like oh my god it's gonna be so
easy to get tickets let's go
[Music]
alright let's read some some of the
[ __ ] questions here for the week was
it really Rita need to swear right there
all right
where are we Sweden oh speaking of that
please come to Sweden last time you were
here I was a little kid and it didn't
know about you but I really liked your
podcasts and your standup is amazing
isn't that like how young that person is
I haven't been there in about five years
you know so what do you be like 15
you're probably still already like five
eleven all those super tall kids over
I'm putting together a nurse Eastern
European tour by the way hopefully for
the beginning part of next year I'm
teasing that that that's what's gonna be
happening we're going to a bunch of
countries that I've never been to before
and but I know I have to get back to
Sweden I haven't been there and way too
way too long so I will definitely get
back there all right
thank you for the compliments my podcast
my stand-up can a comic cover a comedic
bit like a musician no they can't they
can't unless he tells everybody remember
that Cosby bit you remember that prior
bit dear bill one ran away from an
aneurysm birth I had hope true that is
can I want to be standup Oh wanna be
sting you're not an actual stand-up
comedian cover a comedic bit like a
wannabe musician would cover a song I'm
not talking about a paid gig just an
open mic no don't do that because you're
already you're even though you're not a
pro cuz you're not getting paid you are
yeah you don't do that this is there's
no coffee house of stand-up comedy so if
you're a professional like yourself and
I'm putting on a special it should be
total original content the thing is not
all of us are as funny as you but we
still want to make the world laugh and
get a taste of the spotlight and maybe
some groupie [ __ ] too dude if you think
that you're gonna go up on an open mic I
don't give a [ __ ] if you kill with
original material when you get offstage
you still have to have game that's the
thing about being a comedian as a
[ __ ] musician you go up there and you
start singing a song it's [ __ ] over I
mean you can do that at a [ __ ]
coffeehouse singing other people's
[ __ ] songs and it's just going to be
raining [ __ ] vagina comedians we can
go up there for an hour hour and a half
with our own material and you still have
to work for it you know they want you to
still be funny when you get
stage keep being funny keeping they
don't want the other guy to [ __ ] sing
he can sit there brooding you know
smoking his cigarette anyways now your
initial response will probably be
something along the lines no go write
your own material you lazy piece of [ __ ]
you call me illiterate at least I can
write my own jokes oh you trying out
material right now I did my time and the
nightclubs bombing on stage and as a
young skinny redhead and you don't think
I just wanted to go out there go [ __ ]
yourself you lazy lazy [ __ ]
the thing is I don't strive to be a
professional comedian as engineering
pays a lot better and writing my own
jokes seems like too much work dude I
really don't give a [ __ ] about you right
now
you know what I mean a man like I you
know I mean I just want to go [ __ ]
play once one down of professional
football without getting hit and I can
[ __ ] yourself I just want to go on stage
and give the illusion that I'm funny so
maybe a girl will think I actually have
a personality one of [ __ ] me oh now
we're getting to it
now we're getting to it alright so
you're an engineer you probably
introverted you're super smart but you
don't have anything going on with the
ladies so right now you're thinking like
so you'll oh that's funny and then you
think that funny guys that comedians get
a ton of ass I'm not saying there are
guys out there that do but they work
it's [ __ ] or unless you know you
[ __ ] ridiculously good-looking but
like it's [ __ ] work if it is so no if
you extend a comedian you kind of have
like that slumber vibe slumber party
vibe energy like oh my god you guys it's
weird it's like effeminate you know if
you'll but it's just a weird thing about
women if you give off an effeminate
energy you're actually gonna get more
[ __ ] ass than a [ __ ] a guy or I
guess a guy vibe you know to me I mean
look at David Bowie the guy was walking
around wearing dresses there was just
women Prince was wearing high-heeled
shoes his whole [ __ ] that you think
it was like a like the locusts except it
was all vaginas flying at those guys so
maybe that's what you need to do rather
than rather than steal from comedians I
would steal from Prince and David Bowie
and I would think that you guys are all
down there everybody's wearing like the
[ __ ] white lab coat if you add a
little bit of flair a feminine flair to
your scientific your scientist coat
who knows go to work design a bridge
while wearing some [ __ ] Prince
high-heeled [ __ ] boots telling you
you're you're automatically you're gonna
be [ __ ] interesting alright let's
keep reading here I just want to go save
up because I look at it like it's a
scientific report it's not plagiarism as
long as you cite where you got the
information from so if at the beginning
of the set I said something like most
essays I wrote in college this set is
completely plagiarized that's a funny
joke
sir consisting of ideas from people much
smarter than me and the only original
thing I have to say is this opening line
and some [ __ ] somewhere else has
probably already said this too or at the
end of the set I say thanks for
listening if you want to see those jokes
they're actually supposed to be
performed how those jokes are actually
supposed before and go check out the bar
dude yeah you're cutting yourself short
you're actually a funny guy you're just
lazy
you could actually use that opener and
then go into one of the oldest jokes of
all time you know one of those [ __ ]
weren't a fireman's wear red suspenders
look I'm just [ __ ] with you and then
to just talk about being a [ __ ]
engineer and I got no game with women
you only have to be up there for five
minutes all right do that I actually
think you want to [ __ ] do this and I
also think you're funny
from that first line alright so those
are your two options all right if if ya
sincerely from an unoriginal fan from
the great white north you're funny
you're self-deprecating you got enough
here
that it's not crazy to me that you would
go up and do an open mic but uh you know
it's the laziness factor that you just
want to go up there and do other
people's [ __ ] but I understand I
remember the first time I sat down to
write like okay I'm gonna write jokes
it's the weirdest feeling ever it's like
how do you do this like what do I even
[ __ ] what am I gonna talk about how
do I connect one idea to another you're
not supposed to know all right so just
open with that line talk about your life
you know who gives a [ __ ] if you bail
after three minutes that's what I did I
don't even get through the five minutes
and look at me tell it dick jokes all
across the land all right but you're not
gonna get respect from other comics
other open mic course going up there
doing other people's [ __ ] material
and you'll immediately be branded a
thief watch out for this guy it'll be a
bunch of open my cursor vir ly insecure
and they're gonna need a target to
[ __ ] focus their awful childhoods
honor that's gonna be you so I would
open with that joke I would close with
what the [ __ ] you said I wouldn't do
other people's material I talk about my
life and when you're at work you know
whatever put a boa on or some [ __ ] try
to be interesting and uh beg one of the
eggs you [ __ ] work with you know you
guys can't go see Star Wars or something
I don't know good luck to you all right
everybody I'll check in on you on
Thursday I'll I have a great couple of
days you [ __ ] [ __ ] go [ __ ]
yourselves